hello first of all have you met Huy I
didn't tell you my parents are huge fans
of both of you guys so they have great
taste
yes fantastic taste my mom was sad she
could not be here
she's working make sure you rub it in
take a picture it was such a party
without you would you like some ice
cream if you if you would you can grab
it any times anybody like ever turn down
ice cream not me no I've talked to my
friends about this I feel like ice cream
is like one of those things that
everybody has a flavor that they like
like it's all good exactly pizza nobody
doesn't like it yeah and if you don't
you're weird
yeah but I wish I were you but I hear
you just started driving I did you're 20
man I'm 20 I was late to the Train so I
got my license when I was or to the car
I got my license I got my license when I
was like 18 years old I had to film this
movie and so I was forced to get my
license so I could drive a pickup truck
in one of these scenes so and then
eventually I was just like I was kind of
scared to drive I was like I have Oberer
I can get anywhere I need like it's
nicer to be like chauffeur you know what
I mean fall asleep I'm a busy man
eventually overcame the fear and now
I've been driving for four months
I I so don't get your generation like as
soon as I could get a license I was
black it was like Braveheart it was like
I know I feel now I feel the freedom but
like I feel like the uber is were just
so convenient I fall asleep I'm like who
is gonna kidnap me I'm like you are so
trusting Oh Minnie do you have you heard
of Dateline my dad is a huge Dateline
fan so I used to watch those all the
time I had to stop because I was
terrified in my house all the time
literally I still always watch it and
then at my husband was just like it was
getting weird like yeah I got really
were you into cars growing up both of
y'all um yes
my grandfather actually owns an auto
body shop I'm gonna plug him real quick
a action auto body work done I can't
promise you won't sell you a lemon but I
used to work there and he would pay me
like $50 to work the entire summer so so
child labor laws people need to get on
that my sister would work the phones and
she we just get to sit in the office and
like send air conditioning and just wait
for the phone to ring and she could pay
$200 for the whole summer
I was sweeping the yard cleaning all the
cars like there was some inequity there
there was like here favorites it was
kind of reverse gender roles when it
comes to the wages right there I'm
speaking for the man are you a big car
guy
well actually I live in Montana so I'm
I'm more of a horse guy I love horses
that's all you just got this sexy cowboy
and I like it it's a lot cooler I know
what husband writes or I did I liked
riding horses until I bent my tailbone
and then I was like you know what I'm
out I'm not Annie Oakley yeah yeah I was
like that hurts forever yeah
yay but you you actually got your start
in the business very young so what was
your first job other than sweeping your
family's oh boy take me back now I'm
joking it was like 10 years ago but I
guess that is a while ago I started
acting when I was when I was 10 years
old I booked a little show called castle
I heard that you're a fan I'm a huge fan
and I actually remember this yeah it was
so good but my character's name I had a
one episode guest star role biggest I
was so proud of it I ran in one of the
characters I was like I ran up to him my
name was Timmy in the show of course a
little kid named Timmy shocker
I ran up to him and I was like Uncle
Harvey you want to see my baseball cards
and that was your moment that was my big
moment you are hilarious
you are so funny yeah you're like a
walking party so you're on blackish so
who's the most surprising fan that
you've met the most surprising fan I've
met huh what about that okay so let me
start by saying this we got to go to the
White House for the Easter Egg Roll a
couple years back okay I know you guys
can see where this is going
it's pretty good from here but we got to
go to the White House for the Easter Egg
Roll
I've got to bring my entire family went
to the went to the Oval Office bathroom
that there there paper towels are
literally like real towels no the
bathroom was the coolest part it was
like marble all over the floor
I was like whoa those people are like
fascinated by people ya know but the
bathroom was tight yeah we got to meet
Michelle and Barack Obama
it was an amazing attention you can see
my arm isn't around Michelle because I
was like is this illegal am I allowed to
put my arm around Michelle Obama like
Secret Service she's gonna like jump out
of the roof and like I think you chose
wisely awkwardly standing you know
fourteen-year-old markets just like
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going